نريدك أن تستمتع، نريدك أن تشعر
بالأمان، والأهم من ذلك أننا نريد أن
أشعر بالأمان، لذلك لدينا سياسات صارمة مطبقة
إذا ارتكب أي شخص في هذا المسرح
عملاً من أعمال العنف في أي وقت أثناء
العرض، فستحصل على جائزة الأوسكار  يُسمح
لأفضل ممثل
بتقديم عرض سريع مدته 19 دقيقة
لا، لكن بجدية، لدى الأكاديمية
فريق أزمات جاهز إذا حدث أي شيء
غير متوقع أو عنيف أثناء
الحفل، فقط افعل ما فعلته
العام الماضي، لا شيء،
فئتنا التالية هي الفيلم الوثائقي
الذي كما تتذكر هو  حيث كانت لدينا
تلك المناوشات الصغيرة في العام الماضي، ونأمل أن
تسير هذه المرة دون عوائق أو على
الأقل دون عوائق، من فضلك ضع
يديك معًا
ثم احتفظ بهما لنفسك، هذه
النقطة من العرض تجعلك تفوت
الصفع قليلاً